lines along the sidewalk at bad apple
tattoo all these people here just
waiting to get a very specific logo
yeah not just any ink a tattoo of the
new subway series logo and now one man
will get free subway sandwiches for life
that's right jeremy j ford spoke with
the lucky winner today
subway is here promoting the new subway
series with 12 new delicious sandwiches
and a chance to win a lifetime of free
subs i have been thrilled to have made
it this far and actually get the big
tattoo james koontz came all the way
from colorado to be the first in line to
get a foot long tattoo i'm a huge fan of
subway so
i thought about it and i was like well
maybe i should fly out to las vegas
arriving on monday he waited outside of
bad apple for three days to get his
first tattoo it hurt like
tattoos hurt but they don't hurt and now
i kind of get that
because we have one of the best artists
in the country that works here making
the partnership with the subway a great
promotional opportunity along with the
block party
we got a graffiti wall we got free
subway we got tattoos going down most
importantly and yeah we got dj music
going it's a lot of fun especially for
james kuntz who now gets to show off the
subway series i love subway it's
convenient it tastes good it's healthy
and so i am proud of it i have no shame
at all jeremy j ford live local now
well in all eight people received three
inch by three inch tattoos winning free
subs for one year and now the grand
prize winner will get sandwiches for
life awarded as fifty thousand dollars
worth of gift cards
wow